Burkina Faso is mourning it's dead in
the barracks and Eerie silence only
broken by the names of soldiers
all killed by isil Fighters while
protecting a humanitarian Convoy in the
north last month it was when attacked
too many for military leader Ibrahim
trari angered by another humiliating
defeat he staged the coup last Friday
becoming Burkina faso's newest leader
the aftermath of the attack was captured
on mobile phone hundreds of trucks burnt
they were transporting wheat and rice to
Jibo a town of 350 000 people in the
north besieged by isil since February
where people are dying of hunger truck
driver Abdul wahab swadugar survived the
attack he's still in shock
during the attack we noticed our
soldiers were no match they were weaker
the isil fighters were stronger than us
whoever dared to face them were killed
on the spot
two million people are on the Move
fleeing the violence in the north
terrorists tell us to leave our village
our soldiers that are meant to protect
us are not able to kill them terrorists
have come to which a war there will be
no survivors
in the capital wagadugu people are
taking matters in their own hands
collecting food and clothes they will
hand over to the military which plans to
airdrop help for the besieged city of
Jibo
we heard that the Army sent 70 tons of
supplies considering how densely
populated Jibo is 70 tons is nothing
it's not enough we need to do more
it is a war Burkina Faso cannot afford
to lose explained trout rate to
diplomats and a visiting delegation from
the West African Regional body ecowas
the Army has lost control of nearly half
of the country
faced with setbacks commanding officers
appear divided on which military
strategy to adopt the young Captain will
have to rebuild trust in the ranks
command Alder and battle hardened
officers many of whom are frustrated and
unite a fragmented Army that has
suffered too many losses on the
Battlefront Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera